recently my husband and i along with our
two kids traveled across the country to
mexico to see my grandpa who has
declined in health in the last few
months
he is adamant about dying in his own
home rather than moving to the u.s
so my husband built him ramps and got
him some medical equipment to help him
maneuver while he can
this trip was by no means what i call a
destination vacation as we return to our
origin
poverty
we had to bathe in buckets and could not
do it every day because there was not
enough water which by the way was not
the cleanest or even safe to drink
there was no ac in the hot summer
weather so sleeping was difficult and
the nearest store is about 40 minutes
away by car
most people get around either on foot by
donkey or try to hitch a ride on
someone's truck bed we all ended up with
diarrhea and tired without energy to go
anywhere
i had much time to reflect
there are so many lessons i took away
from this experience that i could share
with you but one lesson resonated loudly
in my mind
when i was a child i lived like this
this was my norm
but now as an adult i see things that i
did not see when i was a child
and this particular lesson i owe to my
father
he taught me that no matter what
condition i was in that i should never
expect to receive anything from anyone
much less the people that i love
right or wrong i learned never to ask
for money or gifts or even expect them
to initially always refuse it as an act
of respect to always pay back every
penny i owe
even within family members
and never
absolutely never to desire the material
possessions someone else has
as a child i knew that we were poor i
knew that i could not ask my parents for
lunch money i knew that i could not go
on school trips or have a new pair of
shoes
i knew what our economic status was
but yet i never expected to receive
anything from anyone even those who had
more than me the reason that i think
this lesson is important is because if
you feel that you are poor
no matter what your economic status is
your mindset is that of a victim
that of someone whom the world and
others around owe something because
they had better luck
either your family should help you or
the government ought to give you
something or your employer should give
you better opportunities
this mindset is a black
and it will [ __ ] you
because when you have a mindset that you
are a victim that life has handed you
bad luck and that you lack something
you don't see opportunities you don't
see possibilities
and if they are given to you
you think of the ways that it could go
wrong of the risk of the barriers and
problems to actually achieving or
obtaining that thing
i realize now that by my dad teaching me
never to expect to receive anything from
anyone
i learned respect for those of higher
financial status than i
i now have friendships with millionaires
likely because i never expected even a
dime from them but the greatest lesson
that i have taken away from it all is
that
i can achieve the things that they have
if i am willing to work for it
i now know that my own mind can stop me
from achieving greater things but i am
no different from the millionaires whom
i serve they have made sacrifices they
have seen opportunities and they have
acted upon them
in a society that tries to place our
value based on our income our home the
clothes that we wear
i can now be free
to just be me
to focus on the love that i can give the
ways that i can improve
and free myself from the victim mindset
and gratitude is where it begins
because no matter how little we have
there is always something to be thankful
for
this little act of practicing gratitude
daily can shape your mind train your
brain to see possibilities and
opportunities
and teach your heart that you are
valuable
that you are enough that you can have
the things your heart desires
that you have the ability to create
change no matter what your life
circumstances are
[Music]
and that you are complete
beautiful and worthy just as you are
no matter what marketers and social
media may try to say
you matter you are not a victim you are
a victor
so go out there and claim your victory
i thank you so much for watching if you
like this video please give it a thumbs
up and subscribe so you won't miss when
i post a new video
until next time
bye for now
you